facts average Americans columnist talk
about recent government scandals special
interests and changes to lobbying roles
from the Center for American Progress
this is an hour-and-a-half good
afternoon everyone my name is John
Podesta and on behalf of the Center for
American Progress I want to thank you
all for being here to kick things off I
want to begin by thanking David for
coming back here today I'll give a more
complete file later but it's a pleasure
to have one of our most quoted and
quotable alums back at the center as
some of you know David served as a
fellow here at Camp where he helped to
get our daily publication the progress
report up and running for those of you
who don't subscribe I recommend it
his work was always sharp his analysis
was always hard-hitting and his
contributions to the center were
invaluable and immeasurable and
obviously we're here in part to
celebrate David's book hostile takeover
which I will talk again a little bit
more about but copies are available in
the back or online at amazon.com and
since leaving the Center for the Big Sky
of Montana David has not only become the
world's most unlikely cowboy he has
helped the state elect its first
Democratic governor in 16 years and has
written a quite interesting book that
book as I said will help shape our
discussion today in a moment I'm going
to introduce the rest of our panelists
and give them more formal introduction
to David but first I wanted to say a few
words about our topic today how
corruption affects the average American
we all know that the influence of money
on politics is substantial it's growing
and it has real consequences for you and
me at the state level lobbying is
already a 1 billion dollar per year
industry this is no surprise when in
much of America state legislatures only
serve part time and with a severely
limited staff without a staff to craft
effective legislation for constituents
state legislators often state
legislatures often turn to lobbyists
pre-written legislation even at the
national level with more staff available
to filter the lobbyists authored
legislation
folks like Jack Abramoff spent billions
of dollars and develop increasingly
creative and of course in his case
criminal ways to influence our public
officials consider how Randy Duke
Cunningham was able to take tens of
thousands of dollars in bribes from
defense contractors while living on a
yacht provided by one of them or
consider that Tom DeLay flew to his
court-ordered appearance in his
corporate money laundering case on a jet
owned by RJR Reynolds Tobacco Company
the same company that contributed 17
thousand dollars to his defense it's
important to note though that this
pay-to-play system between lobbyists and
lawmakers runs much deeper than a few
members or a few campaign contributions
luxurious gifts or even golf trips to
Scotland it's an institutionalized
system of corruption and that's I think
what David's book really attempts to
chronicle for instance as our senior
fellow and another former colleague of
David Scott Lilly has pointed out
there's an intimate connection and I
mean that pun only partially between
campaign fundraisers and the lobbyists
that advocate for appropriations
earmarks earmarks often inserted into
the dead of night in appropriations
bills David also worked on the
Appropriations Committee for congressman
Dave o B's well aware of that but I
think in the wake of the Cunningham
bribery scandal I think a lot of people
around the country are wondering just
how many members have been persuaded to
support earmarks not based on what it
might do for their congressional
district but what it might do for them
personally the bottom line is that
corruption has almost become the norm on
Capitol Hill I think it's a problem that
got worse particularly under mister
delays leadership and can only be
corrected by real substantial reform and
not the cosmetic attempts at it that we
saw in the house last week this
corruption on Capitol Hill in our
political culture in general is well
documented in this new book David's
research demonstrates just how lucrative
government can be for those who have had
he'll have a hand in writing special
interest favors into law his insight is
sharp is
lamination is critical and true to form
it's not without controversy well David
and I agree that corruption is a serious
threat to our system of government we
sometimes disagree as we as we did while
we were here I think sometimes I see
legitimate policy disputes that are
occurring where David sees the influence
of money and corruption and I think that
by attacking those who have a
substantive beat with I think you end up
demonizing the legitimate debate and
that sometimes you blur the lines
between guilt and innocence and hinder
our ability to expose real corruption
but I think that David's book I think
really does point to very very serious
flaws in our system to corruption as a
serious problem and it's a problem that
can't be solved by the entire system of
actors it has to be shown demonstrated
and pinpointed which is what he's done I
think the solution requires ultimately
for all of us to work together I shall
add Pingree from common cause and her
right she's here someplace and in the in
the crowd to expose and I think all of
us trying to work together can help
expose to real corruption to push back
on the radical ideas that are leaving
the country in the wrong direction to
restore a positive progressive vision of
government and to do so in a way that
speaks to all Americans today I hope
that we'll have an informative debate
not only about how corruptions affecting
the American people but about how the
progressive community can address it
collectively with that it's not my
pleasure to introduce our panel as I
mentioned David Sirota is the author of
the new book hostile takeover how big
money and corruption conquered our
government and how we take it back he's
the senior editor and in these times a
regular contributor to the nation and
the American Prospect a twice weekly
guests on the Al Franken show and the
co-chair of the progressive legislative
Action Network which is a new
organization which I hope David will
talk about which tries to get at this
question that they at the state
governmental level previously David
served as press secretary to
representative Bernie Sanders as a
senior strategist to Montana Governor
Brian Schweitzer as I mentioned as
the press secretary the house
preparations committee and of course as
a fellow here at the Center for American
Progress after we hear from David we'll
hear from Peter Gosselin he's the
national economics correspondent for the
last Angeles Times Washington DC bureau
and his prolific 30-year career in
journalism he has written for the Boston
Globe the Providence Journal the
Massachusetts transcript New York's
Daily Mail in addition to others he's
won numerous awards for his work
including the Sidney Holman award the
Aronson award for social justice
reporting the National headliner award
and he is a two-time winner of the
George Polk award Peter holds a
bachelor's degree from Brown and a
master's from Columbia and were happy
that he could join us today and last
we'll hear from Rudy to Sarah
Ruiz a joint fellow here at the Center
for American Progress in the Century
Foundation he holds a PhD in sociology
from the University of wisconsin-madison
and has worked at the progressive Policy
Institute the Economic Policy Institute
in Brookings Institution before joining
our institution who is an expert on
voter turnout in public opinion he's the
author of five books more than 100
articles including the disc disappearing
American voter and the emerging
Democratic majority he publishes a
weekly online column public opinion
watch he has a very important along with
another fellow here at the center
John health and a very important piece
up currently on the American Prospect
website which I recommend to you all I'm
now going to turn over the floor to
David to make some introductory comments
followed by remarks for Peter and then
Rui then maybe I'll ask a question or
two and then open it up to the audience
thank you first I want to thank the
Center for hosting this event and I want
to thank the panelists here for for
agreeing to do it I want to thank
everybody who's here especially in light
of the fact that this book is John
alluded to obviously pulls no punches so
I appreciate the forum the fundamental
assertion of this book is that
corruption goes way beyond Duke
Cunningham Tom DeLay bribery and
vote-buying that corruption is really at
the heart of how politicians in the
political debate talk about issues
and that the debates on the major
economic issues of the day are designed
to marginalize the common-sense policies
that Americans support and that public
opinion shows Americans support and
that's pretty well documented in the
book the question for this forum is how
does that corruption affect the ordinary
citizen because as the book says in the
introduction this book is really for the
ordinary citizen I use that not that
term not derisive lis it's it's a term
that's used because I think a lot of
political books and a lot of the
political debate is designed not to be
speaking to the ordinary citizen out
there and that's part of the reason why
cynicism is so heavily on the rise and I
think it's quite clear I think we have a
lot of recent examples as to why as to
how corruption affects the ordinary
citizen a good example is energy our
energy policy up until very recently has
largely focused on a debate between
which oil companies to give which tax
breaks to and now we sit here with $3
gasoline with skyrocketing utility costs
and we wonder why why was the debate
limited essentially to those terms well
because there's large big-money
interests making a lot of money off that
interests that give a lot of money to
politicians it's the same thing with
health care polls have consistently
shown that Americans support a universal
health care program it's usually in the
60 to 70 percent range it goes down just
a bit when you ask folks whether they
would accept some some some sacrifices
including taboo sacrifices like tax
increases that's not talked about in the
political in the political arena it's
sort of talked about in terms of
expanding health care piecemeal but the
concept of a universal for instance
single-payer health care system is not
really ever legitimately discussed as a
mainstream position even though it is a
mainstream position among the population
prescription drugs what's the average
what's the what is the effect on the
average citizen the debate that's gone
on over prescription drugs well we've
had a Medicare bill that cost about a
trillion dollars that gave most of that
to the drug companies because our debate
never asked the question whether we
should have some sort of controls on
drug prices and obviously as many of you
know the Medicare bill was stripped of
its ability to allow the government to
negotiate lower prices for prescription
drugs and so for the average citizen
what we have is the people who are not
covered by Medicare prices are continue
to skyrocket out of control the Medicare
bill for those who receive it provides a
completely inadequate benefit wages this
is obvious the minimum wage has reached
a 50-year low in terms of purchasing
power any bill that comes up to raise
the minimum wage as voted down and if
it's not voted down than the alternative
like we saw last year rick santorum's
alternative was a bill that purported to
raise the minimum wage but would have
eliminated the minimum wage for millions
of people and I think the corruption is
also apparent to the average American
and how it affects them in what we don't
talk about and the best example of this
I think is on immigration this is a
debate that's been roiling the country
it's all over the media it's a debate
that focuses on whether to allow people
who are here illegally to have to gain
citizenship and it's a debate that
hasn't at all talked about one of the
roots of the problem the decimation of
the Mexican economy we have a debate
going on about this issue that focuses
on exclusively on border control and
citizenship questions and not on
questions of how our corporate written
trade policy has destroyed the Mexican
economy since NAFTA has passed tens of
millions that more Mexicans are now in
poverty this is a bill that was stripped
of all labor human rights and
environmental provisions provisions that
may
have moved towards having that trade
policy benefit ordinary Mexicans and so
the fact that we're having a debate in
this country or in the political process
I should say that doesn't even discuss
NAFTA means that we are ultimately going
to get a policy any policy that comes
out of it I would argue will not
actually address the problem and so the
problem will continue all of the
problems associated with illegal
immigration that do affect the average
American those won't be addressed so the
key here is I think and we can discuss
the solutions to this the solution I
would submit has to be a real attack on
the campaign finance system because what
we have now is a government that is
operating on behalf of the big-money
interests who finance political
campaigns now the argument against the
public financing system of Elections for
instance is its welfare for politicians
it's giving money to politicians my
answer to that is you get what you pay
for somebody is going to pay for these
elections somebody is paying for these
elections large corporations in the
super wealthy wealthy largely and that
until we give good people a way to run
for office which allows them to run for
office without being specialists in
shaking down big-money interests for
cash we will never have a government
that we own and that which can actually
solve these problems because the
fundamental problem we face is we don't
have a government
anymore that solves problems polls show
that the public essentially knows that
in all different sorts of ways the
reason why our government doesn't solve
problems is because the policies that it
produces from these distorted debates
that I've talked about these policies
will never ever challenge the big-money
interests that are often at the center
of the challenges our country face so
this is what the book is all about I
hope folks will read it ask questions to
me about it you can email me we can talk
about it here in this debate but I the
fundamental assertion in this book is
that in order to understand corruption
we have to understand that the debate on
major economic issues is artificially
distorted and limited to confine policy
prescriptions only to those policies
that do not challenge the interests at
the heart of our problems
Peter you you've covered this city for a
for a while what's your perspective on
on both David's argument and and where
you see things today in in in our
nation's capital well let me start by
saying I'm grateful to David for the
notice he has given both my work in the
Los Angeles Times both in his blogging
and in the book and for anybody who's
concerned that the midterms of the 2008
presidential debate will be a tepid
affair with the big issues shoved aside
and all the airtime consumed by mincing
small tile Shirota should put your
worries to rest on the evidence of the
panel in the book the next two years
will witness a gargantuan political
clash which is certainly good news for
journalists and I think ultimately for
the country this said I want to start by
putting some light between myself and
and the panel and I'm gonna do this by
you laterally changing my assignment
I'm not going to directly address the
question how does corruption affect
average Americans but I hope address
something that is you find useful I do
this for two reasons first alone on this
panel today I am a member of the
mainstream media and as this crowd knows
better than most were a much maligned
group and indeed David devotes a fair
amount of the book to maligning us worse
yet were eulogized
but my fellow MSN owners and I still
believe that fail often to meet our own
standards though we do the basic job of
journalism remains a useful one and that
is to find out stuff political stuff
economic stuff national security
cultural maybe even spiritual stuff that
can help people get on with their lives
and to put that stuff in the public
domain that's a different job from those
a politician political operative
political thinker I don't say it's
better or worse it's different and I
just like to keep the division of labor
where it is secondly I am NOT as
confident as David that the discussion
that the political parties and the
candidates will have with the American
voters over the next two years will
center primarily on corruption it may we
may look back on this era and see that
this was one of those crucial throw the
bums out moments in American history and
Shirota was a safe but I'm just not sure
and I'm not sure because I'm not sure
that most Americans are ready yet to do
what I think many see as part and parcel
of throwing who Shirota identifies as
the bums out which is to throw in the
towel on the core elements of the Reagan
Revolution free markets limited
government 401ks and forging your own
future if I'm correct the political
conversation will have to begin where
most voters are not in a corrupt
Washington but in their own economic
lives the practical lives of their work
home school kids and it will have to be
conducted at least for now in a language
that doesn't assume they've already
reached a decision about either the bums
or free markets corruption may be part
of that discussion hearing about CEOs
selling out their company's stock while
telling it to employees or political
leaders being jetted to the finest golf
courses of the world will our attention
grabbers for a family scrambling to keep
up the house payments and get their kids
good education but once you've got the
voters attention
what are you going to say about their
lives making their lives better not just
the bums worse now I've been around long
enough to know that talking meeting
voters where they live as they say
sounds like pablum to a lot of
politicians economics is a funny has a
funny way of fading into the background
of becoming a wallpaper in the living
room of American politics but sometimes
every once in a while it jumps to the
foreground and this may be one such time
which brings me to my self-appointed
task which is to briefly describe a line
of stories I've been working along for
the past few years and suggest what
implications they might have for the
coming debate these stories grow out of
a phenomenon that we've seen repeatedly
over the past twenty-five years and
we're seeing again today that of an
economy that the economists say is doing
splendidly thank you very much and that
a large number of Americans perhaps the
majority say they can't find the stories
also grow out of a dissatisfaction with
some of the most widely held
explanations of this mismatch that for
example of former Federal Reserve
Chairman Alan Greenspan who used to
explain working Americans economic
insecurities by pointing in a general
sort of way to globalization and tech
but usually ending up talking about it
as sort of a psychological funk that
would eventually pass that of analysts
who focused solely on income inequality
arguing that the benefits of growth have
become the exclusive preserve of the top
you pick the number small fraction of
Americans and the rest of the country
doesn't appreciate economic improvement
because they don't get the benefit of it
this is an explanation that overlooks
the fact that even in boom times like
the late 1990s well we know that growth
went well be a few percenters large
numbers of Americans continued telling
pollsters they didn't see the benefits
of growth or didn't think they'd last
finally there's the the explanations of
a whole class of commentators who are
coming to the fore again who argued that
it's the nabobs of negativism or some
sort of weakening of moral fiber that's
behind Americans consistently over dark
reading of their own
economic circumstances suffice to say
that none of these explanations
particularly this last one seem very
satisfactory to me in a nutshell the
argument I've made in stories over the
last two years is that there's an
economic trend that's been underway for
the past quarter century that's gone
largely unnoticed and it's not that
inflation has been beaten it's not that
the GDP did this it's not that the stock
market did that it's that there has been
an immense shift of economic risk from
the broad shoulders of business and
government to the backs of working
families from the working poor to the
reasonably rich in part this trend is
the product of fewer employers providing
jobs with the kind of benefits that act
as buffers against bad times in part it
is that government provides fewer back
stocks in case of troubles in part it's
more subtle changes like economic
advances of families that are real
advances but that have left them playing
the game the economic game further above
what safety net still exists and
therefore with farther to fall should
anything go wrong I've tried to document
this trend in two ways by generating a
set of numbers that don't ask the
typical question of where in the
economic pecking order at any given
moment a particular family is rather how
family has got from one point wherever
they were to some other point in the
pecking order did they move in nice neat
hopefully upward increments of income or
did their income fly through the ceiling
and fall through the floor in looking at
this volatility of income rather than
that pecking order question I have taken
a page from the stock market where the
risk of a stock it's data is measured in
a similar fashion by how much it it
swings around and what did I find that
the volatility of family income and that
the risks that I argue it signals have
doubled in the last 25 years the other
way I've thought to document the trend
is by following the lives of people
people like Paul freedo a 50-something
financial specialist who was until
recently the CFO of a subsidiary of a
major French corporation and therefore
the number two or three man in the
company but as a temp told whether or
not to come back every Friday
like Oh Vera Rojas a 37 and Salvadoran
woman who got a toehold on the good life
in the mid-90s when she managed to
combine a unionized hotel dishwashing
job with a job at the LAX Burger King
only to watch the whole thing crumble
when the hotel went on Union and she was
laid off after 9/11
she's just recently gotten back to what
she was making ten years ago people like
Deborah Potter who was one of the top
sellers of group health and disability
insurance in the state of Virginia until
she was diagnosed a few years ago with
multiple sclerosis and had to engage in
a three-year battle with the company
whose very policies she was selling and
whose income as a result dropped from
close to 300,000 to the $30,000 her
preacher husband made until the company
finally started paying now I want you to
notice a couple things about my numbers
and the people that I've been reporting
on things that have I think have
implications for the conversation the
political parties and the candidates may
have with the voters in the next few
years the numbers come out of the
financial markets and the language of
markets that is so insinuated itself in
American society during the past 25
years they don't ask people to judge
their circumstances by some new standard
of an imagined better world but by the
very standards of the markets of risk
and reward that they've been told is the
proper measure of most things practical
and as for the people they are winners
not losers who in large measure have
taken the changes in how the United
States economy works and gotten on with
their lives best as they could by almost
any conventional measures they're either
doing well or improving their Lots it is
only when one looks behind the curtain
and there are circumstances that you
realize a little like The Wizard of Oz
that they are operating without all of
what you thought was there what was once
there for many middle and upper-middle
class Americans to whatever extent those
of you who will be at the center of the
coming political battle
care to draw morals from these stories
I'd hope they'd be these that while
corruption has a place in the
conversation there are plenty of ways to
talk about how
people are living their economic lives
today and how those lives could be
improved that don't start with throwing
the bums out or giving up on free
markets the for Republicans the big
question will be how to ensure in a
free-market economy where households are
bearing increased risks that most of
those who work hard and play by the
rules succeed and in the case of those
who don't their Falls are not lethal
that for Democrats the big question will
be how to assure whatever new
protections against economic upheaval
you offer working families they do not
turn into the big government boondoggles
that rightly or wrongly your party still
has a reputation for creating 25 years
ago political scientist Charles Lindblom
described markets as all fingers no
thumb good on the fine-grained stuff
terrible on the big decisions and
government is all thumbs no finger great
on the broad outlines terrible on the
small stuff we may well be at a moment
where the nation rediscovers wants to
rediscover the virtue of thumbs but in
the discovering the parties and the
candidates are going to be are gonna
have to remember that thumbs and fingers
work together and only together do they
work well thank you you you I want you
to comment on the book but I also think
that that you've thought a lot recently
about Peters challenge and maybe you
could at the end I don't want to
interfere with what you were planning to
say but maybe well in regard to David's
book and one thing I always do like
about David is you know you don't have
to tell him to take the gloves off and
tell him tell you what he really thinks
because it's it's right there in front
of you and I think this is like a very
good book I mean I do recommend it I
think everyone should go out and buy it
if not several copies for their friends
and family about that David for a
blogger um but I think that we have to
realize its limitations I mean I think
it's a very good reference book I think
he does a great job documenting a lot of
the abuses that
powerful economic actors are
participating in these days gaming the
system taking advantage of it for their
own purposes and I think a lot of the
policies he proposes in the book are
quite useful and there's quite a lot of
sort of truth-telling and myth busting
in the book that that again is quite
quite useful but I do think that the
book aspires to do more and I think you
can see that from looking at the very
end of the subtitle how we take it back
well how do we take it back
does David's implicit and sometimes
explicit recommendations really hold up
and that's really where I have my
questions I think in essence what David
is recommending is that we tell the
truth about how big money is corrupting
the system and taking advantage of the
way things work and functioning against
your interests and if we tell people the
truth often enough and loudly enough
they will rise up and demand better
policies and then we'll be off to the
races I don't think that's adequate and
let me explain why
I think this is a classic form or as
close as you can get to sort of a pure
populist kind of approach to it to what
we should do in American politics today
as progressives it's saying let's let's
emphasize the abuses let's get people to
rise up against them let's tap their
anger and you know let's just keep on
you know just if it hasn't worked yet it
just means we have to talk longer louder
under the higher truth content I don't
think that really captures where people
are at today when they look at the
economy and when they think about their
lives there they are aware of a lot of
the abuses that David talks about
they're quite aware and there's actually
well more hostile to big business and
corporate interests and they've probably
been for at least 20 years according to
that the data they do see the system is
being skewed against them in important
ways they're quite aware of the
challenges that exist today to achieving
and maintaining
middle-class lifestyle so that component
of what David has to say will make it
does make some sense to people that kind
of backward looking alarm the system is
being gamed the system is being abused
the system is corrupted
I think people hear that to a large
extent in fact to some extent they
already believe it so you're not telling
them something they they in a sense
don't already know but I think what's
missing here is the other part of the
way the populist analysis or approach if
you will that progresses need to take
toward voters which is the kind of
forward-looking optimism voters don't
see themselves the typical person the
United States does not see themselves as
a loser they see themselves as a winner
they see themselves as someone who is
confronting very serious obstacles to
getting ahead and yet still manages to
get ahead they see themselves in a sense
as a hero in their own drama they see
themselves as part of a system that has
a great deal of resilience and they see
themselves as someone to them and their
family as a as a unit that is actually
confronting these obstacles and managing
to get ahead again as a hero in their
own drama and if all you're telling
people are mostly what you're telling
people is you're abused you're
downtrodden you're not getting ahead
you're going nowhere you're a loser
you're stuck people will not really hear
everything that you have to say let's
look at some data from the New York
Times poll in class in the spring of
2005 because they illustrate this kind
of forward-looking optimist and the
coexists with this the sort of backward
looking alarm about the way the system
is currently function 70% of people in
this survey said they had already
attained or would it take the American
Dream two-thirds said they were doing
better than their parents dinner to
comparable age 56% said they expected
their kids to do better than they did at
a comparable age 80% said with hard work
and with a willingness to work hard you
could still get it you start out poor
and still become rich in this country an
amazing 45% said they expected thought
it was very or somewhat likely that they
themselves would become wealthy some
these are optimistic views and they
reflect the fact that people see
themselves as succeeding in the face of
great obstacles and if you cannot speak
to people's aspirations but only to the
ways in which they're having a hard time
you will have a very difficult time
reaching them about the kind of economic
policies you won and I think in that
regard it's it's of some significance
that despite all the good policies that
David reviews in the book he has
actually very little to say about
education which is a key aspect of how
people aspire to get ahead in this
country and how they see their children
getting ahead I proposed here the kind
of summarize and way of evaluating
David's approach and other approaches to
for that matter what I call the white
working-class test and if you want some
more in this and in fact this whole
discussion there is a very I bought a
very useful discussion David's book on
the talking points cafe book club last
week where I and David and a number of
other people had at these issues and I
recommend it to you but here's the white
working-class test look at whites
without a four-year college degree what
I define is the white working-class
these are overwhelmingly voters of
moderate to low income and by definition
of modest credentials but do they see at
this point their aspirations for a
stable middle-class life linked to
progressives views and oppressive
program I don't think they do and let's
sort of roll the tape here on the own
the latest data and 2000 Gore lost these
voters by 17 points the 2004 carry loss
these voters by 23 points that swing
alone is enough to explain that Bush
Bush's victory and 2004 over Kerry that
alone and then if you look at the voters
within that group who have the most
purchase on a middle-class lifestyle
those between thirty and seventy-five
thousand dollars in household income
those between thirty and fifty K Kerry
lost by 24 points those between 50 and
75 K who are White's without a four-year
college degree Kerry lost by an
astonishing 41 points you cannot lose
this badly among this huge a sector of
the electorate and expect to build a
progressive majority coalition these
voters according to my analysis of
census data are still over slightly over
half of US voters and even within
another 10 years they'll still be 46 to
47 percent of voters
so does David's approach pass the white
working-class test I don't think so I
don't think so because these voters see
themselves again as succeeding in the
face of great obstacles they have
aspirations they want to know how they
can get ahead they want to know about
their opportunities they know they're
getting screwed to a large extent
they're already quite cynical about the
system but they want to know is where
you stand on helping them get ahead and
they need to hear that combination of
backward-looking alarm and
forward-looking optimism but I think
truly does characterize these kinds of
voters and give myself a little plug and
John help and we do have a lengthy
article now that I think is finally up
in PDF format on the American Prospect
website called the politics of
definition the real Third Way when we
argue that progressives need to define
themselves in terms of a common good
progressivism you know details can be
found in the article but basically that
argues we're all in this together we can
provide everyone can be provided
opportunity everyone can realize their
aspirations and that doing that is what
progressivism should be about but again
I refer you to the someone like the
article for all the copious details
about that so in sum I think that David
has provided a useful reference book but
I do think we need to be cautious about
its applicability as a strategic
framework Thanks I think we're gonna
give David okay that's done to respond I
think actually both Peter and Rui were
some extent pointed I think in similar
direction and I think that David as I
was listening to Rui my guess is that
there's a part of this you really would
agree with which is the analysis of of
where people stand today but would argue
that you have provided something more
into context this book well why don't
you have at it well there's a lot to to
go out here um I do agree with with Rui
that we do need an aspirational politics
in fact I think that this book provides
a very aspirational politics every
chapter has specific policy goals every
chapter includes heroes who have been
fighting the hostile takeover and the
end is an entire chapter on exactly how
I think one man's opinion how we can
take our government back I think that
rui cites the right the right poll
numbers people are aspirational I think
there's a contradiction in what he said
though he said that people already know
the truth people already understand the
world around them he cites the New York
Times numbers the survey numbers showing
that people think that there's
essentially all sorts of social mobility
in America but obviously those people
haven't read the actual stats The Wall
Street Journal last year came out with a
long story about how social mobility is
at a historic low in the United States
The Economist soon corroborated the same
the same thing that social mobility in
the United States is often lower than it
is even in European and Scandinavian
socialist countries so I don't think
people really do know the full extent of
what really is going on I think they
have a sense of what's going on but I
don't really think they fully understand
and I don't blame ordinary voters or
citizens out there because as I document
in this book the entire political
propaganda system is designed to make
people not think about those things and
I I don't mean that to pick on you Peter
but but but but but we talked about the
free market I would argue that that's
one of the most vicious and overused
theories that doesn't really relate to
what kind of an economy we actually live
in here's a page 9 in my book just to
give an example of what I'm talking
about
what I basically say is this free market
we're told means we must have fewer
regulations that protect citizens less
taxation in the rich and no mandates on
business to fulfill any social
responsibilities other than increasing
corporations bottom line that's the free
market free at the same time this free
market is to be ignored when it might
actually benefit ordinary citizens so in
one breath we have politicians tell us
that price controls for medicines are
bad but restrictive patent laws that get
abused protectionist patent measures
they're they're good that's something
that's part of the free market
regulations against energy price gouging
are bad they violate the free market but
government handouts and subsidy
subsidies to big oil companies that's
considered good by the free marketeers
protecting American jobs at home that's
bad that's against the free market but
government through institutions like for
instance the export-import bank
subsidizing the outsourcing of American
jobs that's good
that's that's that's ok in other words
they tell us that that government and
the free market is only OK when it only
helps big-money interests so again the
point of saying that is I think that the
population is fundamentally misled and
so I don't blame ordinary citizens for
for instance within the context of this
debate thinking that there is all sorts
of social mobility in America and that
America is the place where you really
can as opposed to most other countries
go from rags to riches because that's
what's being told that's the story line
that story line is not an accident it's
deliberate
where I do agree again is on
aspirational politics I think that what
we have to do and this does where this
relates favorably to what what you said
I do think that what we have to do is
not just scream corruption corruption
corruption throw the bums out throw the
bums out in fact I when I started
writing this book I made very carefully
I took care to include how we can take
it back and as I joke to some some
friends earlier if I wrote this book ten
years from now I would just eliminate
how we take it back I would just you
know it's over we're done it's there's
no way to take it back just how big
money and corruption conquered our
government period probably would've been
a shorter book too so I think it is
fundamental to connect corruption to the
challenges people face to show that
corruption in our government is a direct
obstacle to the aspirations of society
to show that corruption is an inhibitor
of people's the idea that people have
opportunities and that curing corruption
addressing corruption fundamentally
through for instance public financing of
Elections and that's just one example in
the book that addressing corruption is
actually a way to increase and expand
opportunity in this country Peter I
think we're using the term corruption in
very different ways I mean one one and
then I think David and his opening
comments sort of pointed out the fact
that that he sees his problem is a lot
bigger than even the the pay-for-play
schemes that we see on Capitol Hill
today or certainly Duke Cunningham or
other people with who have actually
violated their oath by elated the law
and our mr. Cunningham case I headed for
prison but I think David's using the
term corruption in a much broader sense
I suppose that that is really in a
winner-take-all economy which we we seem
to be building that the winners not only
get some fair advantage by the fact that
they have more resources have better
you have more access to capital but that
they've actually now jerry-rigged a
system to make sure that not only do
they start off with all those natural
advantages but then they sort of by
public policy outcomes that that
exacerbate the trends that you that you
described and I wonder whether in that
context you would take up the initial
charge to you and and and just reflect a
little bit on whether you think that the
that where we are now have a policy
context where the kinds of things that
you're documenting are the kinds of
economic trends that you're documenting
are really being exacerbated or enhanced
or you know we're pushing the the edges
out on the on the problems that the
people that you've chronicled and have
had to deal with or whether it's just a
kind of natural aspect of the way the
economy works in goal in globalized
world today let me take runs at that in
a couple different ways but David argues
in the book not just that there's
corruption in the payoff sense not just
that there's corruption in the buying
outcome sense but in the very early part
of argued that they own the language too
so that that stuff just doesn't get
discussed
that is a sweeping claim and there
before you make it you in making it
there needs to be an appreciation for
sort of how we got here and one way you
can do that in one way John I try to do
this in some of the stories I've done it
it's just talk a little about the late
70s and early 80s I suspect that this
audience has no sympathy for Ronald
Reagan but they were an astoundingly
screwed up time the economy was a mess
and something needed to be done and the
notion that we are where we are because
of this kind of deep-seated corruption
of both payoffs policy outcome bought
policy outcomes and bought language I
think isn't true to the history we've
lived through over the last 25 years
that that you now in the light of you
know now that grew older and wiser we
can look back and we can you ought to be
able to acknowledge that Ronald Reagan
had something when it came to the
economy we did need to do something the
question I think is that you know do we
need to keep going in that direction or
is there a as there has been throughout
American history I have we reached a
pendulum point you know at the outer
swing of a pendulum and that I think is
legitimate and I think that that if if
someday in the future we look back and
say yes this was the time we should have
made this swing and then it's not made
now you can say well it was delayed by
many of the things that Serota is
talking about but the the question of
whether or not we got here via
corruption I'd love
you know I swore myself I was gonna
stick to my knitting and you know I'm
the reporter I haven't reported out that
question so I can't answer it
definitively my instincts are no we did
not get here by corruption we got here
because we faced a problem and
policymakers at the time we faced it
tried to tackle it they tackled it with
ideological blinkers they tackled it in
ways that advantage to some and
disadvantage to others but they had a
real problem that they needed to tackle
and they did the same question yeah I
think Peter makes some very good good
points about that I think the assumption
that the political economic model we
have today is solely attributable to
corruption i think is just mistaken
there's a lot of ways in which the
United States has changed in the last
thirty years that are actually our
responses to things like globalization
of technological change is a different
world now we've been getting arguably
the wrong answers to how to respond to
that big business as corporate interests
have taken advantage of the shifts in
the system to try to press their agenda
and it's not been a very good agenda but
that said it's not like the aggressive
or center left actually has that correct
and easily perceivable solution to this
as well Harold Meyerson I thought had a
very good article in The American
Prospect the other day talking about the
decline of middle-class stable loot
especially blue-collar jobs the united
states and was centered around talking
around people in the detroit area and
you know it's the center left all over
though industrialized world doesn't have
particularly good answers now to how to
deal with this increase in stability the
increase in competition from the rest of
the world it's not just a result of
corruption as a result of change
corruption makes it worse but corruption
is not the sole cause
well I I'm gonna bout to turn it over to
the audience for questions but I I need
to spend one minute being the clinton
guyana pal because we've referenced
we've referenced ronald reagan and his
political change of course ND and the
impact on on the economy i just wrote a
few statistics down i think david takes
issue with some of this and i want to
get him to respond but but with with
reference back to reagan in clinton's
eight years a hundred a hundred times
more people were lifted out of poverty
than in then in the reagan eight years
seven point seven million to be exact we
had the lowest poverty rate since the
late 70s the longest expansion in
history the obviously of with respect to
fiscal discipline a record deficit
turned into a record surplus the
contrary the flip of what we saw under
Reagan's term in office but in addition
of that I think for the middle class
there were twenty three million jobs
created we have five consecutive years
of real wage growth family income rose
17% median income for african-americans
grew by a third Hispanics by twenty four
percent the wealth gap got bigger in
although people added to their assets I
think that the that the combination of
policies didn't-didn't
it may have slowed down but it didn't
stop the wealth camp from spreading now
David I think takes issue even with that
and and suggests that some of those some
of that some of that I mean I think he
has a particular hang-up on trade in
NAFTA and an open markets but I think
that in general I think he may
characterize even though that level of
economic success as being having a dark
down side which is the which is the the
influence of big business on that core
set of politics but but again in from my
perspective
the the the mission of the
administration was really aimed
centrally and trying to raise incomes
and tries to great living standards for
citizens and I think we did pretty well
in doing that so I wanted to give David
I've shot at responding to that and
responding to the Reagan point is
welcome first and foremost I I as a as
somebody who's worked for Democrats and
who still considers myself a Democrat I
think I make it pretty clear in here
that I think that the Clinton
administration was a heck of a lot
better than the previous administrations
and subsequent administration's I think
that we are in part living through some
of the negative consequences of the
Clinton administration economic policies
that's why I say that this problem that
we're dealing with is a bipartisan
problem NAFTA has for instance work to
destroy American wages and undermine
Americans benefits it's pretty simple
why it's a trade deal that was
deliberately free of major labor human
rights environmental protections there
was there they weren't in those deals it
wasn't in the China PNTR deal and I
think the China PNTR deal I think it was
signed in 2000 I think it was and now it
you know so there wasn't really a
Clinton administration to to sort of be
at the head of the helm when the
ramifications of that kind of deal went
into effect and I think that we are
living through some of that and I'll
just give you one example here's the New
York Times on the seven-year anniversary
this is of NAFTA not even of chaya quote
this was buried in a story of course
quote wage increases are being held down
especially in manufacturing by a
persistent fear among workers about
losing their jobs despite the strong
economy Kate bronfenbrenner from Cornell
documented how after NAFTA was passed
many companies used NAFTA as a threat
for workers when they went on strike
when they demanded better wages one
company in upstate New York for instance
brought vans that said moving to Chuck
and moving to Mexico outside of the
factory when workers were striking
so I do think there were means made
under the Clinton administration
especially especially in terms of some
of the at least preserving the social
safety net I think that and I want to
get to these two points that I've sort
of forgot to get through but tie into
this you know rui said that the that my
book is doesn't mention education I
think that this is one of the great
myths the education myth that I've
written about is it if we just educate
everybody everyone just gets basically a
college education our economy is gonna
be great everyone's gonna find a job
well I would argue that with the trade
policies that we have in some of these
other policies crush the middle class
will have a nation of highly educated
low-wage workers or perhaps unemployed
workers that that you cannot educate
your way out of problems in an economy
that is undermined by structural
policies designed to tamp down and crush
the middle class the second thing I
think that I wanted to get to and I
think this is important and it again
relates to the to the Clinton record is
that you know people say well you can't
be too populist Bill Clinton proved that
that you can't run on sort of populist
themes and you know corruption stuff
touches on the the populist themes well
Bill Clinton at least as I remember it
and one of his famous speeches I have it
cited in the book I'm not going to quote
it from memory but he basically ran as a
populist one of his speeches he said he
would never sign trade deals with China
if they don't better treat their workers
he would never sign a trade deal with
Mexico unless there were labor and wage
standards I mean that is an almost a
direct quote and I can pull it up if
people don't believe me and then he went
ahead two years later and signed NAFTA
and then a couple years later he signed
the China trade deal and so this touches
on another thing that rui said about how
you know Kerry and Gore lost this many
white working-class voters and that
means progressives aren't connecting and
I think that's a subtle but dangerous
linguistic change conflating Democrats
automatically
with progressives or populist I think is
a major mistake the fact I would argue
that Kerry and Gore didn't do better
among the working class and let's just
take oh hi Oh for example it has a major
white working-class demographic is
because Kerry had absolutely no position
for instance on trade this is a state
that's lost three or four hundred or
maybe even five hundred thousand
manufacturing jobs the Democrat runs for
president and has no real position on
trade and perhaps among many workers the
last thing they remember about Democrats
and Trey was that a Democratic president
rammed through Congress NAFTA and China
PNTR which sold those workers out if you
go into a state like that you're not
going to be able to attract white
working-class voters unless you actually
speak to the policies that are hurting
them and just to close I've had some
experience with this personally out in
Montana when I worked for Brian
Schweitzer both in 2000 and 2004 his
campaign was openly based on populist
economic themes in 2000 it was going up
against the drug industry in 2004 was
going up against a corrupt former
administration and it was basically
running as an outsider to the political
establishment saying that it basically
been bought off and these themes and
this politics is not just pie in the sky
this is politics that allows Democrats I
think to win in red states and have a
whole article documented in the American
Prospect about that that this is not
just sort of moralizing or wishful
thinking that in districts conservative
districts across the country Democrats
can win by brink by fusing together or
by realizing there's a way to bridge a
gap between progressives
and traditionally conservative voters by
being willing to stand up to big money
interests
great you wonder what you I think there
was a little bit of a challenge in
somewhat what David said but I don't
know I could also open it to them the
question right there well we got could
you identify yourself and go for go with
Mike yes my name is Bill neo I write
about the future of the Democratic Party
and David I sent you a long essay which
may have scared you away from the bite
lane up
I want to connect your observation maybe
maybe corruption is too strong a word
but in inherent in the Reagan Revolution
was the elevation of of the entrepreneur
not just from the pedestal where they
always are in American life but to the
altar one nation one market under God is
a good way to summarize that and the
language follows trace the use of the
term bottom line from an accounting term
to showing up in sermons and every type
of other type of discussion but here's
my my connection by elevating the
entrepreneur to that status the
countervailing powers and brakes on that
type of power that existed even under
Eisenhower republicanism have fallen
away the institutional checks and I do
feel we're living in the late 1920s with
hedge funds and derivatives just over
the horizon it's not just me that senses
that the crucial checks and balances
from other forces in society including
populist and progressive countervailing
powers are missing and that helps pave
the way for corruption and I just like
you to comment on
I think you touch on an important point
that that that entrepreneurship has been
used as a as a something to to deify and
I think it is a very important part of
an innovative dynamic economy I think
though what what this book argues is
similar to what you're saying is that
you know having a government that is
wholly owned by corporate America does
not serve ordinary citizens and it does
not serve small businesses and it does
not serve entrepreneur it only serves
huge businesses and hugely wealthy
people who have enough discretionary
income to buy a seat at the table and I
can just give you one example for
entrepreneurs you know the the
bankruptcy bill was written and touted
as a pro-business piece of legislation
that's another red flag word
pro-business everything-everything that
gives away the store is pro-business
everything that protects ordinary people
that's anti business well what we found
out from the bankruptcy bill the
pro-business piece of legislation was
that the new reforms the gutting of
bankruptcy protections was actually
destroying and particularly hurting
entrepreneurs that that that it was
driving down the the was a big New York
Times story about about how
entrepreneurs were less willing to take
risks knowing that if they didn't come
through they'd be indentured servants
thanks to the new bankruptcy bill and we
can see this attack on entrepreneurs and
small businesses throughout I mean you
know the Walmart's ability in local and
state government to by itself subsidies
that other companies small businesses
can't get obviously give Walmart for
instance a huge advantage in moving into
communities and destroying small
business and entrepreneurs that doesn't
serve business as a whole that doesn't
obviously serve society it serves huge
companies and Walmart's just one example
has a huge amount of money at its
discretion to buy those policies can I
just comic-con if if I understand what
you said correctly you like David
believe that there has been a the
language has changed in a way that
stacks the deck against progressive
Democrats whatever you want to call me
and I I think you have to ask yourself
do do we really have an electorate that
doesn't get it off there may be you
there certainly years we certainly have
examples in political campaign years
where certain words certain images
basically turn into our polarizing and
and and they you just can't get out from
under rabbit but over the long haul are
we do we really have a problem with our
language do you really think that if if
you believe that then how is it that I
mean how is it that American politics
has worked as well as has worked over
two and a half centuries I mean I just
don't it's hard for me to understand
that this is a language problem that we
face I mean it seems like there's some
more practical things that need to be
discussed other than you know the
deification of the word entrepreneur
because Democrats don't have a clear
narrative and I want them to get them
that is part descriptive and warning but
also optimistic and and we have the
solutions hedge funds and derivatives
are the worries of serious people like
Paul Volcker George Soros and so forth
and Kevin Phillips not not the least see
far more ominous clouds than you do and
I and I want to be fair to the average
citizen they're so busy keeping their
heads above water I don't know I don't
understand hedge funds I know there are
serious problem and I do worry about
that and I think you should too and you
do have to have an upbeat sight you just
can't say despair you have to have a
narrative and I want the party to get a
narrative I want progressives to get
about it out lady right there I can see
yes I'm Celia Wexler I'm with common
cause and I'm very interested in this
whole notion of language and what
happened to it and I don't know if the
book gets into this and I'd really be
interested in all the panelists
commenting on this but you know during
the Reagan years about 85 percent of the
Federal Communication Commission's
regulations were repealed and that did
have a great impact on the structure of
media and media ownership open the door
for media consolidation that got worse
and worse as we got into the 90s and
1996 and whether you see a connection
between shrinking number of owners of
media more bottom line pressures on
reporters so that in-depth reporting is
harder to find at least in mainstream
media and this whole issue of who owns
the language how issues are expressed
and discussed and what American people
may or may not know about their own
plight and how it relates to government
I'll try to take it real quick just
about the book and language
the book essentially asserts that
language is used as a justification for
predetermined a predetermined agenda
that that the impetus in politics today
largely is to serve big-money interests
whether that doesn't affect occasionally
helps and often hurts ordinary citizens
that the language is art is the public
justification and that the reason why I
would argue that people tend to tell
pollsters they know something's wrong
can't exactly put their finger on
exactly what's wrong and they also say
that they want far different solutions
that are being proposed by the
government the reason that is is because
people are under a flood of language
that makes them think that the political
system is trying to work for them that
when a politician goes out and says why
they're voting for the bankruptcy bill
for instance because it's pro-business
and we need to crack down essentially on
lazy people who don't pay their debts
that was the big I'm paraphrasing here
but that was the big narrative during
the bankruptcy bill we just want to
crack down on these lazy people who
don't pay their debts let's forget about
the fact that most people declare
bankruptcy because they have a medical
problem in their family or a death in
the family let's just it's just lazy the
idea is that there's a a they know what
they want to do they've known what they
wanted to do for a long time and they
create false storylines now is it sort
of George Lake off or is it is it George
Lake off and and Frank Luntz exactly are
they do I think that they're always
sitting around you know coming up with
the exact right word no and I think the
book says that it's the overarching
storylines that can be put into specific
language that I think is where
corruption and the corruption I talk
about is justified
Peter maybe ask you to pick up on the
media concentration point and and what
you're you know observations are about
the structure of you've been in the
business for a long time half things
really changed are obviously bigger to
death I'm yeah yeah let me see if I can
do something before I address that which
is go back to what I said before I guess
the argument that I'm making is that
Americans oh it's not that in certain
debate the debate over bankruptcy bill
certain certain ways of framing the
story weren't in politically important
they weren't politically important and
it's not that the language hasn't
changed in some systemic way over the
last 25 years it has changed it's that
Americans aren't innovative people who
can figure out the way how eventually
how to talk about what bothers them and
what they want in whatever language you
give them the pitch I guess I mean I I
realized as I was sitting here that what
I just said dear was about language -
I'm pitching my way of talking about it
versus somebody else's way of talking
about it I guess all I'm saying is that
the language that has come out of the
last 25 years of economic change the
language where bottom line means more
than an accounting term but something
greater where 401 K has an iconic
meaning that you know that that language
is strong enough that it's sort of what
we've got on the ground but that it is
rich enough that people can talk about
their economic circumstances using it
and affect what I see myself as having
done and saying okay I'll play this rule
with with business language whew you're
you want to play at the free-market game
we'll talk about risks and rewards hey
we have got some great reward signals
you know we've got the stock market
flashing you know all the time where
those where the risk measures where the
Bissman Wow insurance companies have the
risk measures you know the hedge funds
have the risk measures what's your risk
measure what's the risk measure for
American fan
well I'll tell you what it is it's the
it's the Nostrum don't put all your eggs
in one basket that is sort of that's
what we got we're given certain nostrils
and so my argument is go with the
language we got in front of us but but
it can be used it is rich enough to talk
about the circumstances that really
matter to Americans today on the
question media concentration I just say
to you this that I mean I I'm inside
bees so I don't know what's really going
on I mean you know I work for one of the
very largest media companies in the
country whose stock is doing terribly
thank you very much and who that is
rumored to be in play I've been allowed
to I'm appearing at this panel today I
spent years covering the stuff I've just
talked with you about and I'm going to
spend the next year trying to craft a
book out of it it may all fall on its
face right the the the jig did all the
journalists in this room have that the
gig that we all have that we all love
may all collapse is it going to collapse
because there's concentration or for
some other reason I just say there are a
lot of forces at play and it ain't just
concentration that's doing it I mean the
Internet has got a lot to do with it and
so again I'm I'm nervous as hell about
it but but I'm not sure that you can put
it to corporate concentration really
politics of definition yeah I think that
this is a reasonable time to bring that
up I think the concept that the language
that is being used in political debate
you know whether or not it's being
driven primarily by corporate
concentration in the media or not I
think it's a mistake to think that it's
the content the type of language that
we're using nowadays it's really at
fault in terms of progressives being
able to define themselves clearly in the
public mind and in the minds of voters
the problem lies I think more with
progressives themselves and their
inability to define themselves clearly
in the public mind voters minds in terms
of what they are for
I think at this point most voters know
for example the Democrats are the party
that is more anti big business they know
if you ask them in polls they always say
that Bush in the Republican Party
overwhelmingly they say that's the party
on the side of big corporation if you
ask them which party is for the middle
class the Democrats have overwhelming
advantages of 30 to 40 points I mean
these are big and the question is why
can't that be translated into a
political advantage for progressives and
into a majority coalition I think the
answer is people don't know what
progressives are for what are they for
on health care what are they for in Iraq
I mean how are they going to deal with
globalization how do they stand on a
variety of questions and what's their
overarching philosophy we recommended in
our analysis the politics of definition
that it should be a common good
progressives and that's what we're for
we're not just against you know we weigh
big business runs the sort of turns
things to their advantage we're for a
common good progressivism puts the
common good at the center of political
debate and public policy so I think it's
not a matter of having to you know break
up the media monopolies and
fundamentally change the language that's
used in everyday discourse it's a matter
of defining what progressives are for I
think we've got time for a few more
let's go to the back why don't we do why
don't we take a couple of questions at
once and first a gentlemen the far back
and then time will come forward slime
from Bob progressive Maryland I've got
two questions that aren't related and
there are four anyone one of you for one
has there been interesting examples of
when progresses of use political jujitsu
till I get big money interests like
maybe work of a friendly competition or
something to effect another corporation
you know capital strategies that kind of
thing and secondly I'm curious about
what your insights are into the rise of
the the Netroots its impact on politics
today issue advocacy but also electoral
campaigns that
maybe we'll get one from the net root
expert Darrin's right in trouble
Tom Matt see with moveon.org I just
wanted to ask for Rui and Peter so you
what makes because I was going through
the book and for each chapter there's
nine ten you know eleven of different
ideas and you know this thesis that
you're not going to you know by standing
up and fighting for something against
something you're not showing people what
you're for I'm trying to understand how
you get that out of David's book and so
that's what I wanted to ask about
because I think actually you know Paul
Wellstone said you you can figure out
what you stand for by fighting you know
or you sometimes look you know fighting
against something you figure out what
you stand for that was the quote and you
know it strikes me when you're fighting
against you know the bush energy policy
you can figure out you want better
efficiency you know more conservation
more alternative sources etc etc so I
don't understand where this thesis comes
from progressives don't have ideas in
this book every chapters got ten of them
that's a great question we'll take one
more that will let the panel answer at
all al Milliken Washington in a pen
writers particularly when it comes to
the corrupting economic influence of
China is every American consumer buying
Chinese a willing participant in their
own corruption good question David okay
I will try first of all ok so I'm gonna
try to take these in order so is there
an effort to to take big-money interests
and try to get them to work for ordinary
citizens interests you know I I talked
with somebody recently I said the next
book I might somebody could write a
whole book and I'm not a historian
somebody could write a whole book about
how the economic history of America is
one set of corporations ganging up
against another set of corporate and so
I think that the the idea that you can
you can do that is is a good one and
it's an important strategy I think for
instance on health care I'm
I'm excited at the idea that not that GM
workers for instance are potentially
going to lose their health care but that
GM might see that a universal health
care system is in its best interest what
is that in reality that's one set of
corporations you know employers
potentially ganging up on health
insurance companies you know I think
that might happen with prescription
drugs I think that might also have them
with energy you know high energy prices
may hurt consumers it also hurts small
businesses and big business so I think
there's a strategy to be found there I
haven't written about it hugely in this
book I sort of mentioned it but that
that that's definitely an avenue for for
policy thinking the rise of the Netroots
I think you know when I talk about
public financing of Elections I think
the small d democratization of
fundraising has been a positive effect I
don't think it will cure the the system
like a public financing system does but
I think that has a positive effect I
also think that the the the ability of
small information smaller information
gatherers to have a bigger platform that
the Internet provides I think that's
terrific
I think it's very important and it might
be a factor in both of those might be a
factor in fighting against hostile
takeover
the third question about my book that
was a good question that I and then is
every American complicit when they buy
Chinese goods that's a very good
question I don't think I think the
answer is no I think the what's
complicit I think our government is
complicit in creating an economy that is
increasingly based on goods only
produced from foreign manufacturers I
think you can't blame the person who
walks into the store and if ever in they
you know they need to provide for their
kids they need they need to you know buy
subsistence goods the issue is is that
we have economic policies that are now
making sure and helping to make sure
that Goods more Goods and more of the
economy is sold off to cheap overseas
labor markets that's the problem
Peter you went up yeah um Tom scratching
ah look I want this be clear I don't I
don't take a position on the boy I mean
I came in here and I I didn't answer the
question that it was posed it was posed
to me because it doesn't seem my place
okay so I don't I don't say anything
about the weather whether they're there
being again something is you did whether
there's any programmer that or not
that's really all right where are you
taking off all right well I'm not afraid
to take a decision so well first of all
I need just about the Netroots I'm a big
fan of the Netroots I'm arguably a
member than ever it's myself and I think
the key aspect of the Netroots isn't so
much their political position on any of
these issues but rather their
fundamental pragmatism they've repeat
the other side and they want to reform
the Democratic Party and the progressive
movement in general to do that so I'm
all for that but it is gonna make a
difference what we say and how we say it
which brings me to this point about the
way David pitches things in his book I
don't think that the way he pitches
things is fundamentally aspirational I
think it is fundamentally
us-against-them class against class in a
sense our interests against theirs and
that to get the issue is not ours is
there I mean I think the policies leave
some stuff out there isn't much about
education I think education is
profoundly important for the typical
American today and it is how they see
their selves get ahead and I think it is
telling it left out but even in terms of
the policies that are in this book the
question is how can you get the policies
I mean there's nothing I mean if those
policies could all be implemented
tomorrow it would be a better country
and a better world but how can you get
people to support them and I don't think
you can generate the kind of support you
need particularly among the white
working-class voters I'm talking about
if you we don't need to change the
overall language that's used in this
country but we do need to be careful
about how we use language and the
message we communicate to people and if
they think that you're saying that
you're a loser that you're not getting
anywhere your life is stymied and stuck
you're not going anywhere the MOE social
mobility in this country is fake frankly
I think the concept that you're going to
win over
lot of people in this country by telling
them social mobility as a crack is just
ludicrous people I mean people believe
in social mobility in this country
they've always overestimated the degree
of social mobility in this country they
probably overestimate it more today but
that is what people believe that is what
people want and if you tell them they're
not getting what they want even though
they think to some extent they are I
think you've lost them to some extent
right from the get-go I also think that
you're not going to make that much
progress in getting to the policies you
want if and this gets to something John
mentioned very early in this in this
panel if you demonize those people with
whom you have honest disagreements or
have some disagreements I think there
are people who have different views
about trade in the progressive movement
there are people who for example you
know feel as I do that we need to
combine aspiration with with criticizing
the way big money does have undue
influence on the system but they're not
all the enemies they just have a
different idea about health aggressives
can I succeed in this in this country
and those are reasonable disagreements
and we have to pay attention to them
because you need a majority coalition
coalition if you hope to succeed you're
not going to succeed again simply by
telling the truth about big money and
putting some progressive policies out
there and assuming that you know one
connects to two that's that's kind of
your strategy right there
so you know again it's a reference book
pretty good as a collection of
interesting policies though there are
some things left out pretty good but I
think I'll have to stick with my
position I think is a strategic
framework it is sadly lacking let's take
a couple more and then David can respond
to worry in the context of well just
take these last two and then and then
we're gonna have to call it quits
yeah it'd be brief to please I am as
you're someone older voter here but not
that much older a grievance a lot of
what you said and I I think it would
help me and those folks in Middle
America not here in DC not of the East
Coast who are not voting who are
concerned
who have concerns about the different
labels and the language the language the
negative language I believe that comes
out is from the political campaign
people that are hired to put out all the
negative language and words about
whomever is running I do believe you've
got to say what you're for so could you
please explain to me as a perfect voter
who's somewhat disillusioned what is the
difference between a Democrat and a
progressive when or how will those
elected officials in on the hill and at
the state and federal level and local
level state federal local city all
different levels begin to talk to each
other whether you're a dear nan da are
and say it's okay
we can disagree to agree so we can make
some good decisions and and get those
folks out to vote because I believe
you're going to need to mentor some
younger people to run for office who may
not agree with the democrat or
progressive or conservative or whatever
policies and is this going to lead to
the possibility that independent voters
are going to rise up and say let's throw
the bums out until we can get some
reasonable people in office that's what
that's the Tom Friedman theory well one
last question right up here if you could
be quick and then we'll let the panel
wrap up
it's gentleman right here
Church and freelance correspondence Davi
I'd like to bring to the very basic if
you said that the rule is deep in the
camping balance
I think Sweden have to be do ways or
explain firstly this usual people say
all came in find said that the money
just spent in the camping process could
you explain that
knows money give reach the politician
and second is it user Peter were buying
and oka okay you spend money you buy
something but they are so no connection
about money
nobody topic on tension between the
money and an outcome and third is is
okay you spend money you buy something
you can somehow come and people always
say well if nobody spends on money then
they are nothing be done okay I think
we're we're we have very limited time so
I think what I'm gonna do since both
those really were directed at David is
just like David wrap up and okay and
finish up okay - Ruiz point that that we
won't win and essentially we you you
can't win you can't get to a point where
you can make the policies in the book
real unless you have short essentially
winning politics I don't disagree and I
think there we have to understand
there's a division between an outside
role and an insight role politicians are
going to think about the two-year
election cycle in front of them I don't
dispute that I've worked on campaigns I
know what that's about but what the
right had and what I think that our side
doesn't yet have is a strong outside
infrastructure to hold the road for the
policy outcomes we want so here's an
example on the social mobility thing we
start talking about how voters you know
have a have I you know the stats
basically show that voters have a have a
different conception of social mobility
in this country that actually exists how
do we how do we bring the perception
into reality well I think look at the
look at what the right is done when when
the right started pushing when they're
outside
organization started pushing Social
Security privatization 30 years ago for
instance everyone said you're crazy
you're absolutely insane and then two
years ago we saw a President of the
United States running around the company
champ country championing now it didn't
pass but the fact that they had even
gotten to that point shows a role for
public education that outside
organizations and institutions not
connected to the electoral campaign
process have a very important role to
play in better educating the public and
that is what this book is about this
book is not a short-term political
strategy guide second question a
Democrat versus a progressive I've
written a little bit about this my basic
way to put it is I think the difference
between a Democrat and a progressive I
think there are a lot of progressive
Democrats is that a Democrat I think is
more comfortable using taxpayer money as
a way to solve problems and a
progressive often sees other
alternatives in simply challenging
big-money interests rather than simply
trying to buy off big-money interests so
for instance for instance a proof a more
liberal or standard D Democratic
solution to the energy problem is tax
subsidies to you know perhaps green
energy companies other oil companies a
more progressive I would argue solution
would be to have a federal price gouging
law to have a windfall profits tax to
fundamentally challenge the oil
companies to challenge the idea policies
that challenge the idea that these
companies should be able to make as much
money as they want no matter what the
social ramifications similarly on drug
on prescription drug prices a more
liberal solution is to take a lot of
taxpayer money and throw it at the drug
companies to get them to give drugs to
seniors a more progressive solution I
would argue is to allow the importation
of cheaper fda-approved prescription
drugs to lower the overall price of
drugs and/or to like other
industrialized countries consider some
version of price controls on drugs so
that when Americans so that Americans
aren't charged the highest price for
drugs and the
rather than simply throwing a huge
amount of taxpayer money at the
companies that are already ripping us
off on the question about campaign
finance reform as I understand it the
question was about you know what is
bought for for the money and I would say
that again this book is filled with
individual examples of what is bought
for the money but I would say that in
order to understand how things are
bought for the money we have to
understand that the campaign finance
system the way elections are run demands
that candidates respond more closely to
big-money interests than it than they do
to ordinary people I mean think about
just being a politician if you're
running for office and you know you have
to raise a huge amount of money the
first people you're going to listen to
are the people who provide that money
because the next time around if you want
to get reelected you need that support
so until we create a system that allows
other people a different means of
running for office a system that doesn't
select for people who are simply good
either good telemarketers or good at
shaking down big-money interests we will
not have a system that we the public
owns well I want to thank David I want
to actually have the last word because I
think on the definitional point
David's definition of progressivism
really I think it comes full circle and
it really equates to populism and I
think that again I'd mentioned it's a
beginning we talked about it but I think
there's a different there's a different
way of thinking about a progressive
government that's really about the
common good and searching for a proper
role for government in regulating the
marketplace but also as an instrument
for helping people achieve opportunity
and I don't know whether you I I don't
think they've would disagree with that I
think though that that his emphasis on
kind of big-money liberalism I suppose
is a is it is a kind of pejorative way
of thinking about using government again
as an operative
a place for opportunity for for people
to go to college to succeed in life to
have a decent public education system
and to some extent to provide the the
basic social compact that that is
increasingly fraying I think in in the
United States but I think that David's
book is is is provocative it's it's as
as really said it's it's at a minimum
it's a great source book at a maximum
it'll hope I think it'll force us to
push our thinking forward as we develop
plans for how we can bring the country
together so we thank him for that
there's still copies available you can
buy them at the back of the room I'm
still watching out for you happy david's
happy to sign them and we welcome him
back we'll probably have to have them
back for a full-scale debate on nafta I
think that that we not only we disagree
a little bit about the facts as well as
the circumstances of all that and I
would just one factual correction David
President Clinton didn't sign NAFTA but
he did side the labor and environmental
side agreements so with that